Oh what is going on YouTube today we
have a special guest from please
in today's episode we are going to be a
slow down special interview with the
movie star in the Asian community Jason
Chan is a Chinese pop star or some [ __ ]
let's just stop all the chatter and get
right to it huh
hey hey David are you ready for this
interview it doesn't look like I'm ready
I'm always ready my man no David this is
a really serious interview okay so fine
but I bought this interview I don't give
a [ __ ] I don't know the guy is hey hey
guys here's the daily so let's just get
this home so I have a major Korean pop
star what's it like being the leader
beep what are you talking about you're
Korean pop group this I'm not gonna
cream pop group wait wait I don't have a
lot daddy do Do You Know Who I am
gee g-dragon g-dragon teacher g-dragon
did you just say g-dragon are you are
you serious right now I don't want
anything like a funny guy you april
fools
who is that guy dude that's justin chon
from Twilight
what's while I tagged a Japanese game
the script so so it's a gay vampire
movie village no it's not a gay vampire
movie okay vampires that twin will the
Sun - ha - lil bro bed gasps vampire
Mountain hey Ben hi my name is Jeannette
well just enough ulis we've got off to a
very bad start
so uh yeah no totally cold man like you
know disgust of happens to you like yeah
so um as a lead actor in Twilight series
what's that feel like wait hold on
what's that dude no no I wasn't the lead
I was just 40 character Mohamed how
would you like to portray a vampire
in this epic straight on oh hold on um I
wasn't a vampire man I was a human being
I see you did you watch the movie I oh I
was one of her friends at school
let's just get into the nitty-gritty man
there were a lot of homosexual in
windows throughout this whole movie and
there was no almost sexual innuendos
it's why I again so you want to leave
you were to vamp I didn't have a dick
your mouth look you do what my god you
what the party's on my fat piece of [ __ ]
without my weight yeah you're back what
this interview and get ugly ass hair you
can talk [ __ ] about my hair now your
hair looks like you got in a fight with
the weed whacker and laughs my friend
look I don't like you you don't like me
let's just get this over with you know
III have an amazing idea how about you
let me conduct this interview you want
to come do this interview yeah
go ahead boss so what was it like to
have a number one single being a k-pop
group in the u.s. that you went viral on
YouTube and I see what you're doing is
because I called you g-dragon so you'll
be a little smartass saying I look like
style I get it what I'm saying is so I
that must be amazing I saw you on Ellen
so even Ellen you had a concert in in
New York you know you got signed by
scooter broad Justin Bieber's manager
credit rejection she's just a dance
t just a [ __ ] dance man show it to us
you got it
yeah it's everybody it's gonna love it
all you guys are going to this is what
you've been waiting for is how to do a
step by step by side I'm not gonna teach
you my by side you don't like you just
slow down
what are you doing
you know
you